ونعود الان الى قمه مجلس المجلس الاوروبي
معنا من ريكيا وزير خارجيه الجمهوريه
اهلا بك اذا انشاء سجل لحصر الاضرار التي
لحقت باوكرانيا اليوم خلال هذه القمه ما
اهميه ورمزيه واهداف هذه الخطوه
جزيلا على الاستفاضه اولا نحن حقيقه قررنا
وضع السجل بالاضرار وهي اداه لتوثيق كل
الاضرار التي الحقتها روسيا وقواتها في
العدوان الذي تشنه على اوكرانيا وهذا
السجل سوف يستمر سوف يستخدمه في كل
الاجراءات القادمه ضد الاتحاد الروسي ونحن
ايضا بحاجه لانشاء محكمه دوليه
لتعلمون ان هناك قضايا عالقه في المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه وهناك تحقيقات تتم داخل
اوكرانيا نفسها اذا هذه خطوه عمليه من اجل
اوكرانيا ومن اجل الاتحاد الاوروبي
الدوله للتوثيقي كل الاضرار التي الحقتها
روسيا باوكرانيا ولكي تستخدم في كل
الاجراءات اللاحقه
وللحصول على التعويضات الضروريه من روسيا
في المستقبل نعم يعني اذا نظرنا الى
المجلس في حد ذاته وهو يعني ينظر اليه
بانه محدود التاثير واصلا غير معروف يعني
حتى في الاوساط الاوروبيه بالتالي الذي
يمكن ان تغيره هذه الخطوه من مجلس صلاحيته
وسلطاته محدوده
اكيد ان مجلس اوروبا مجلس اوروبا هو الجهه
الاقليميه
وايضا تتذكرون ان
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده مررت قرارا
حول التعاون في هذا المجال اذا هناك تعاون
على المستوى الدولي ايضا ودعونا نتذكر
اوروبا
يتالفوا من بلدان تتعدى الدول الاعضاء في
الاتحاد الاوروبي هناك بلدان تنتمي الى
اجزاء اخرى في العالم وقد وضع معايير
عاليه ومحترمه في اوروبا لاحترام حقوق
الانسان واحترام لحكم القانون وايضا
معايير جيده في مجال القانون الدولي لهذا
السبب لا استطيع ان اقول ان تاثيره او
صلاحياته محدوده روسيا كانت في يوم ما
عضوه فيه لكنها
الحرب على اوكرانيا في العام الماضي نعم
طردت منه روسيا ولكنها وصلت حربها في
اوكرانيا وبالتالي الى اي حد تعولنا على
ان تكون هذه الخطوه بدايه جر روسيا
لمحاسبه
ومساعي الاوروبيين بان تكون هناك محكمه
جنائيه
اولا دعونا لا ننسى ان المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه قد اثرت مذكره بحق السيد بوتين
رئيس الاتحاد الاوروبي ومذكره الاعتقال
هذه يجب ان تقوم بتنفيذها كل البلدان
المنضويه تحت نظام النظام الداخلي للمحكمه
طبعا الامر الثاني الامور لا تحل على
مستويات المجالس والاروقه وهذه هي التي لم
تحل لن تحسم هذا الحرب سيحسمها المقاتلون
الاوكرانيون على الارض لذا يجب ان نقدم
لهم كل اشكال الدعم ثانيا نوثق كل
الانتهاكات التي ارتكبتها القوات الروسيه
طبعا كما بخطوات تشبه ما حصل مع المانيا
النازيه في اعقاب الحرب العالميه حيث تم
جلب
الامام العداله هذا لن يتم في عام او
عامين ربما لكن فكره التحقيق العداله
وعجله العداله يجب ان تدور وتستمر في
الدوران وهذا امر يجب ان يكون واضحا
للجميع الى اي حد يمكن القول ان هناك وحده
صف في مجلس اوروبا بكل دوله التي يوجد بين
بعضها خلافات حتى وايضا هناك خلافات بين
بريطانيا مثلا والمحكمه الاوروبيه الحقوق
الانسان كيف تؤثر كل هذه الخلافات
والتباينات على مساله التعامل مع روسيا
كانت هناك دائما قضايا تحتاج الى النقاش
هذه امور طبيعيه في اي منظمه الدوليه ولا
يمكن ان يكون هناك اجماع شامل وفهم كامل
لكل
الاولويات ولكل طرق عمل واولوياتي
المنظمه كلنا بلدان ديمقراطيه وكلنا لدينا
سياساتنا واحيانا نبحث هذه الامور وقد
تحصل خلافات في وجهات النظر لكن انظروا
الى نقطه مهمه المجلس اوروبا كان موحدا
تماما في الاجراءات التي اتخذها في العام
الماضي ضد روسيا نعم في مساله الولايه
القانونيه للمحكمه الاوروبيه لحقوق
الانسان هي قضيه طويله الامد وانا اقول ان
المحكمه الاوروبيه لحقوق وهي قضيه مهمه
للمملكه المتحده لكن المحكمه هذه بحد
ذاتها خدمت الغرض الذي انشات من اجله
ووضعت معايير عاليه ولهذا السبب هم طبعا
الاحكام هذه المحكمه نهائيه وانا افهم ان
المملكه المتحده لديها بعض الهواجس ومواعص
القلق لكن في النهايه يجب ان ناخذ بعين
الاعتبار من جهه ونحترم كل المؤسسات
الدوليه التي الدول مجلس اوروبا اعضاء
فيها تاتي هذه القمه في الوقت الذي يجري
فيه بناء تحالف دولي لمساعده اوكرانيا على
الحصول على مقاتلات اف 16
وايضا في ظل الحديث عن جهود الاعمار كيف
تتوقع ان تدفع هذه القمه
بهاتين المسالتين الى الامام
هذه ليست القمه التي نقرر فيها مساله
الطائرات نفاثه
كخطوه رمزيا
قلت لا تخلطوا اعمال المجالس المختلفه في
اوروبا وفي العالم
شكرا لك كنت معنا اذا على هامش قمه مجلس
اوروبا رئيس عفوا
وزير خارجيه